it was super frustrating I went with my
mom to the most storied cathedrals to
Western medicine and in every instance I
experienced what I've come to call
diagnosed and audios and I have a lot of
respect for medicine in fact when I
started college I wanted to be a doctor
I was pre-med for the first few years
but truly in none of those doctors
offices was diet or lifestyle ever
really brought up I'm Dave Rubin and
this is the Rubin report as always guys
click that little subscribe button on
YouTube so you might just might see our
videos now joining me today is a New
York Times bestselling author of genius
foods and the author of the new book the
genius life max Luger here welcome back
to the Rubin report so good to be here
thank you for having me New York Times
bestselling author yeah last time I was
not no yeah you were about to become
about to become I didn't know it at the
time I had no idea how well genius foods
would ultimately do but I'm super
grateful humbled that it's reached big
audience is now published in eight
languages around the world it's super
cool I was in Colombia I was in Bogota
and I had like a line of Spanish
speaking fans lined up to get their book
signed and you know we could barely
communicate but it was just so so
gratifying to see that you know how does
it change one's life to become a New
York Times bestselling author um you
know I think is I mean does it really
like level up the amount of stuff that
you suddenly get cuz people like oh this
guy actually does know what he's talking
about it's not just a book about yeah
yeah it's a credential and you know I'm
very I never misrepresent myself I mean
I'm I write about health and science but
I do it not from not with having a
background in academia or medicine I'm
just um passionately curious and I it's
a topic you know that I think is the
most important topic there is but the
fact that the book continues to be it
wasn't just sort of a there's this
metaphor in in book sales you know when
you when you launch a book it's like
throwing you could be throwing up either
a feather or a brick and like a feather
is what you want to happen because the
feather it goes up and then it kind of
floats the break just ends up coming
right down to the fact that
his Foods has kind of just stayed up you
know and it continues to to sell well to
me as a testament to the quality of the
work really ultimately and as a writer
that's the best form of flattery that
you can that you can get you know that
your writing is embraced and that it
continues to do well so yeah um super
thrilled it's given me the opportunity
to write this book the genius life I
have since launched my own podcast which
is also called the genius life so it's
allowed me to get to do what I love to
do full-time and as you know it's a
great thing to be you know to work for
yourself and to and to be driven on your
own steam yeah it's a pretty sweet thing
and you're building a studio in your
apartment which I know a little
something about that so that we could do
a separate show on that but for people
that didn't see our first interview
we'll link to it in this so they can
jump back but one of the things I find
most interesting about you and you and I
now go back like 6 7 years so before you
wrote genius foods your story on how you
came to kind of care about this stuff is
well it's deeply personal but it's also
pretty fascinating actually could you do
like a quick recap on that absolutely
yeah I started as a journalist I was a
generalist working for Al Gore's Current
TV which was not a my role there was not
as a a flag bearer of his political you
know ideas and environmental ideas I was
I got the job right out of college and I
got to cover stories that were important
to me and they ranged from health
technology to politics occasionally but
when I left that job after six years I
started spending more and more time in
New York City which is where I'm from
around my mother and I'm firstborn child
very close to my mom she started at the
age of 58 to display the earliest
symptoms of dementia and she had a very
strange confluence of symptoms she had
symptoms that were more indicative of a
memory disorder and then she had
movement symptoms which would indicate a
more parkinsonian complex like
Parkinson's disease and it was something
that was traumatic to witness you know
when we got the the initial diagnosis
were you literally the first person that
noticed anything or was she noticing
that something was going
she knows she was she started to
complain of brain fog memory problems
but we didn't have the vernacular in my
family we had no prior family history of
any kind of neurodegenerative disease
and interestingly my mom's mom my
maternal grandmother was she lived to 96
and she was cognitively sharp until the
end so she was my grandmother was not
demented and so the idea that my
grandma's daughter my mom could somehow
be succumbing to this condition that I
think most people assume to be an old
person's disease just didn't compute
didn't make any sense yeah and so when
my mom was initially prescribed those
you know the drugs for Alzheimer's
disease and Parkinson's disease that was
the first time in my life I'd ever had a
panic attack you know I'm a pretty chill
guy but it was I was alone in the hotel
room in Cleveland Ohio googling the drug
prescriptions would hit which I think
anybody would do in in that position and
the severity of the situation really
dawned on me at that moment and from
that point on I decided to dedicate you
know all of my free time to
investigating why this would have
happened to my mom what could be done to
help or what could be done to prevent it
from happening to myself and that began
about eight years ago and that was a
struggle obviously you know watching my
mom descend and and become more and more
handicapped by the disease and that's
what motivated me to write genius foods
and to do all the work that I've you
know that I that I've put out and what
occurred after genius foods came out was
I mean equally surprising and equally
heartbreaking I was in the middle of
writing this book when my mom turned
yellow and you could I mean usually if
you turn yellow you know it's either
gonna be jaundice or you've eaten too
much beta-carotene you've eaten too many
carrots yeah but what happens with
jaundice the whites of your eyes
actually become yellow that's kind of
what distinguishes it from just you know
eating eating too many sweet potatoes
and my family rushed her to the
emergency room they did an MRI
and what they discovered was not a
gallstone which is typically what you
know it'll cause a blockage in the bile
duct cause bilirubin which is a pigment
to back up into your blood what they
found was much worse it was a tumor on
the head of her pancreas and she was
diagnosed with pancreatic cancer and 90%
of the time when pancreatic cancer is
diagnosed it's already progressed and it
was three months and she was you know it
was the most it was barbaric and brutal
and and that's what she ultimately
passed from but the fact that my mom had
these two freaked health conditions two
of the most feared conditions known to
humanity it motivates me every day to to
learn more to teach more and to just
stay open and curious and always be
willing to challenge my assumptions and
my beliefs about what it means to be
healthy in the 21st century
yeah well that's why I think your story
is so cool I mean just like you're a
good guy but you've also like even when
I you know follow you on Instagram and
you do a lot of like you know don't eat
this this kind of stuff and you it's a
very it's very human you're not like
beating people over the head with all
this and I want to get to some of those
techniques and little tricks that you
use to make things a little bit
healthier but when you're when your mom
got diagnosed and then subsequently when
you did all of the things that you tried
to do over the course of that time was
anyone else talking about food or was it
all just like this is what you take this
is what you take well up it here if this
happens you do this like was there any
like eat more avocado no it was super
frustrating I went with my mom to the
most storied cathedrals to Western
medicine and in every instance I
experienced what I've come to call
diagnosed and audios and I have a lot of
respect for medicine in fact when I
started college I wanted to be a doctor
I was pre-med for the first few years
but truly in none of those doctors
offices was diet or lifestyle ever
really brought up and the contrast
between what I was experiencing in the
in the clinicians offices with my mom
and what I started to discover in the
medical literature there was just this
big value in between the dearth of
information and the despair that I was
seeing there with my mom and the
optimism that I was reading about in the
in the medical literature and ultimately
what I
did was I realized that I had met media
credentials and I started to reach out
to scientists and researchers who were
the authors of the papers that I was
reading and they echoed that that
sentiment of optimism and yet at the
point-of-care with my mom what I
experienced was was anything but
optimistic so I really had to take it
upon myself and I think when you're a
patient my mom was scared she was
confused she didn't have a framework for
understanding health or science or
anything like that I did because I had a
I had had a lifelong passion for the
topic but but really I think there are a
lot of people in in her shoes that are
met with the same kind of I don't know
like hopelessness and yeah you're right
I mean what they what what every doctor
would ultimately do would titrate up the
dose of a medication that she was
already on throw something new into the
mix and by the time my mom passed she
was on ten different pharmaceuticals I'm
not even being hyperbolic and there's
just no way that a physician can have
you know any idea of how each of those
pills are interacting with one another
in a body that's growing increasingly
frail and sick if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about lifestyles instead of non-stop
yelling check out our lifestyle playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlists they're both
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell